[Musique]
la saison froide est arrivé
noël célèbre à la fois la naissance du
christ et la fête païenne plus ancienne
du solstice d'hiver les nuits les plus
longues
[Musique]
le feu de saint-jean signifiait
l'abondance pour le village plus
familial la bûche de noël présage la
fécondité pour le jardin pour
l'agriculture et pour la basse cour
madame jaujard s'occupe avec ses fils de
60 hectares et de 11 cents brebis elle
est l'une des rares paysanne à pratiquer
encore les traditions de la bûche dans
l'intégralité symbolique et religieuse
de leurs rituels
madame victorine qu'est ce que vous
venez de faire avec cette bûche de noël
l'avoine l'orge et du maïs du pied pour
récolter
la nuit prochaine
[Musique]
quel genre de légumes vous avez mis les
carottes et pommes de terre
ail persil
quel genre d'ordre vous prenez pour
faire la belge n'a pas chuté
parce que c'est pour rapporter le fruit
quelle prière avaient voté oui notre
père
l'eau bénite vous est venu c'est le curé
qui vous a donné on a été chercher
un ovni vendredi c'est à l'église d'un
bénitier l'église
depuis combien de temps vous donnez
pratiquez-vous la bûche de noël
où mme samia très longtemps
il ya très longtemps depuis votre
enfance on rit j'étais gentil
vos parents l'ont toujours fait qu'un
jour pendant combien de temps allez-vous
faire brûler cette bûche jusqu'à six
derniers douze jours pour un tri comme
les douze mois de l'année mais oui vous
faites aussi brûlé les graines en
gérance y est qu'est-ce que vous au fait
j'ai jour 1a volaille alors vous pensez
que a réussi la prouesse à mes yeux oui
la face à mayer pour l'année
et légumes vous les fait voler à nos
jeunes et je m'en servirai comme quoi en
métal ou en brioche en images et vous
pensez que c'est un bon effet mais sans
doute sur la sortie mais oui et le tronc
de la bûche puisque vous au fait avec
les cats où ça n'est jamais dans un
petit coin et pire il paraît que comme
ça file l'orage quand rapporte
ce que vous dites là soit efficace il
faut être catholique ni certainement si
je n'étais pas croyable que je ferai
part je fais partie de la religion
pourtant éric et
vous avez fait une bénédiction mais vous
n'êtes pas prêtre pensez vous passez
donc votre bénédiction est valable mais
je passe
si je l'étais
cycle 1 je crois que j'ai bien fait et
ne vous fait pas concurrence aux curés
le
je vais à la messe
comme tout le monde
en tout cas vous le curé vous n'avez pas
fait leur marque en maintenant au ta
maman
il m'a dit que j'en avais entendu dies
était tradition convié qu'il y ait
tourné bienvenue
vous même vous êtes la plus âgée des
personnes de la maison lui et l'enfant
qui est avec vous c'est le plus cher
alors on prend le plus violent le plus
jeune et le plus vieux et le plus jeune
et le plus vieux pourquoi je pense
qu'une tradition pas mike toujours dans
la famille alors j'ai toujours suivi
mois de l'enfance a vieilli mairie
comme jadis les moines du haut moyen-âge
où les seigneurs normand du 16e siècle
modem jaugent air entendu avec effroi
dans sa jeunesse
rodet la chasse démoniaque formé par les
âmes des damnés on l'appelait chasse
elkin ou chasse galerie
mais j'étais en train de préparer du
linge pour mes enfants c'est une bûche
entendu un bruit
alors ça faisait du bruit comme des voix
dans le ciel
fusil puis alors j'ai peur c'était
d'écrire et puis des bruits comme des
chênes qui sombra celui que décrit dans
des bêtes ni creed de charme tout
aussi pas bon vous aviez quel âge que
vous avez entendu ce jeudi 30 quelques
années et où est-ce que ça s'est passé à
blanc tacheté blanc le jour n'ont rien à
payer d'un coeur
je pense
peut-être d'hier ni envers c'est une
région de chant de forêt au yen à coups
de formules abbaoui n'étaient pas venus
de paris et ce genre de choses c'est
plutôt vers la forêt que vers la plaine
c'était dans la direction de la forêt
vous avez eu peur brigitte père et comme
le dit votre famille le fus pas
réveiller non de famars email lendemain
matin je suis à raconter il m'a dit on
pense que c'est une idée qui t'a fait
alors ma belle mère a été vue nous
valons ils me disent ici elle dit dans
le temps moi j'ai entendu dire que des
anciens saisi cgt des enfants n'était
pas baptisé alors qu'ils revenaient beau
se faire baptiser
haut mais ça s'est passé ça passe comme
un nuage
cette chasse était connu dans la région
oui je vais un oui ma belle mère m'avait
dit qu'ils viennent avec l'avez entendu
et moi c'est la seule fois
jamais je l'avais entendu avant et après
[Musique]